Hmm.
Well that,
that has huge implications for MMA cause that's the big debate right now.
How long should someone get suspended for and for how long,
you know,
how long afterwards should they be considered enhanced?
Yeah.
You know,
like they're giving people some pretty significant suspensions now for steroids,
like two years.
But you know,
there's this Jon Jones case and I'm sure you're aware of,
do you wear this?
Yeah.
Where he's testing positive for the metabolite,
for the longterm metabolite,
for a very small dose.
He's never tested positive for a short term metabolite.
Which testosterone?
No,
it's not testosterone.
It's um,
what is the stuff Terrana ball.
Yeah.
And essentially it's tainted supplement and it's not,
it doesn't have any performance enhancing benefit in terms of like the,
the,
the amount of the dosage that he's tested positive for,
but it's lingering in his system because the protocols for,
um,
the weather ability rather to detect these metabolites has increased rapidly.
And over the last year it's just unbelievably more sensitive to the point where,
you know,
they're detecting these infant testimony,
small levels of these metabolites.
And there's also seems to be some sort of a pulsing effect when your body
releases these infant testimony,
small metabolites and then doesn't,
so you'll test negative and then the next week you'll test positive,
but only for the longterm metabolite,
which is an indication that there's no real administration of the performance
enhancing drug.
Yeah.
So it's real.
It's,
it's in everybody's mad.
There's so many athletes that are mad about it.
And from what you're saying,
and for this study that Doctor Rhonda Patrick highlighted,
it's,
you know,
it's especially for SOS willingly taken something,
seats.
There's a lot of those like once a doper always a doper type of things.
There is that.
Yeah.
But she,
the Jon Jones situation is very tricky because she's so good and he's so
dominant that people just assume that he's been doing something his whole career
and when you catch them,
they're like,
Aha.
That's the reason why he's so good.
Yeah.
It,
it may be,
but it also might be,
he's got phenomenal genetics.
He has two brothers.
He was just the,
the best of the guys who are taking drugs.
That's a different situation because that's a sport where at least in the time
period where he was competing,
everyone was doing something.
Yeah,
100% they had to go meet.
All the UFC is like that.
It's not right that it's not.
It's not.
It can't be.
They're too strict.
The side is knocking on doors at six o'clock in the morning,
pee in this cup and you,
you do hear about positive tests,
but the amount of positive test versus the negative tests is overwhelming way
more guys are not doing something.
It used to be the opposite.
It used to be in the nineties everyone was doing something.
We were just talking about this on the fight companion podcast that a big issue
is grappling.
Grappling competitions are overrun with steroid users because no one's testing
and these,
I mean it's the smell test is off the fucking charts.
You're looking at these guys,
they're just ridiculous.
Just jacked,
low body fat,
super high mass and their training Jujitsu all the time too.
So you would think it would be very hard for them to maintain muscle mass,
as well as be able to train the way they're training with technique and drills
and cardio.
And it's very difficult to maintain muscle.
Any,
any concurrent strength,
endurance training scenario.
Very difficult,
very difficult.
So there's a real issue with some of these guys competing this way and then
trying to transition into MMA.